au large du pacifique des scientifiques
scrute avec angoisse un écran de
contrôle depuis les profondeurs lugubre
de l'océan un robot sous-marin leur
transmet des images inquiétantes
dimanche cheminée rocheuses éjectant
apanage brûlant est toxique que sont
venus chercher les scientifiques dans un
endroit aussi hostile il se pourrait
bien que ce soit à cet endroit au fond
de ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le
pacifique que la vie soit né ça paraît
fou mais la science ne sait toujours pas
comment la vie a pu émerger nulle part
il ya bien les théories des expériences
mais contrairement ce que vous pouvez
croire jamais à laboratoire n'a réussi à
recréer la vie depuis zéro et ça
pourrait peut-être bien changer
prochainement grâce à une comète au fin
fond du système solaire et cette vidéo
est présenté par ecoscience provence
alpes côte d'azur à quoi ressemblait la
toute première forme de vie sachez qu'on
a retrouvé le fossile en australie le
voici ouais un peu décevant certes mais
ces bandes blanches c'est la trace de
vie la plus ancienne qui était retrouvé
à ce jour on appelle ça des
stromatolites des sortes de croupe de
bactéries primitives fossilisés date de
naissance il y à 3,48 milliards d'années
à cette époque la terre n'a même pas
encore fêté son premier milliard
les continents sortent à peine des
océans l'atmosphère est irrespirable il
y a même pas de couche d'ozone pour
bloquer les rayons uv mortels si ces
bactéries on puisse survivre dans un tel
environnement c'est forcément au fond de
l'océan protégé par plusieurs mètres
d'eau qui filtrent le rayonnement
mortelle du soleil cette théorie
n'explique cependant pas comment des
bactéries sont apparus à partir de rien
juste d'aktehom et de molécules de base
c'est une question qui tourmente est
déjà charles darwin au 19e siècle selon
lui un moment il existait une petite
crique isolée au bord de la mer l'eau y
est est saturée d'éléments chimiques de
base chauffé par le soleil quelquefois
électrisé par la foudre et dans ce
bouillon chimiques naquit par hasard des
molécules jamais vu jusqu'à lors c'est
cette théorie qu'a voulu tester le jeune
stanley miller reproduire les conditions
de cette petite crique dans des tubes à
essai il y met de l'eau ça sera l'océan
il imite du méthane de l'hydrogène de
l'ammoniac ça sera l'atmosphère
primordial il fait s'évaporer l'eau qui
rencontre un arc électrique ça sera la
foudre il n'aura fallu qu'une semaine
pour que l'eau prennent une teinte
brunâtre cette étrange dans ce tube il
n'y avait pourtant que des molécules
simples est ce que c'est une
contamination miller analyse l'eau et
n'en croit pas ses yeux il y à des
acides aminés les briques de la vie ce
qu'on retrouve dans les protéines cette
étude sera une révolution dans l'étude
de la chimie prébiotique malheureusement
contrairement à une idée reçue on est
très loin d'avoir créé la vie aucune
bactérie aucun brin bas et rennes ne
naîtra de ce liquide marron qu'est ce
qui nous manque alors c'est là qu'il
faut que je vous parle d'un phénomène
fascinant la sélection chimiques tu
connaissais la sélection naturelle bas
c'est pareil mais avec des molécules on
étudie comment des structures non
vivante peuvent évoluer en s'adaptant
imaginons que dans notre soupe
primordiale secret est un acide gras
chimiquement les acides gras sont
polarisées ce qui signifie qu'un côté de
la tige va être très attiré par l'eau
alors que l'autre va essayer de s'en
éloigner le plus possible ça tu peux le
voir dans la réalité avec les bulles
d'huile qui a dans sa vinaigrette et
rigolait pas la vinaigrette est vraiment
étudié sérieusement pour expliquer la
vie car un moment plein de ces bulles
d'acides gras se sont associés en nappe
nappe qui a fini à force d'être remué
par les vagues par se refermer sur elle
même pour former une belle enveloppe
sphérique ça ressemble furieusement à
une membrane de cellules un cocon
protecteur ou des réactions complexes
peuvent se produire sans être perturbé
c'est là dedans quinze jours va
apparaître l'adn grâce à cette molécule
notre prototype de cellules va pouvoir
pour la première fois sur terre se
dupliquer or pour voir se reproduire
selon la nasa c'est la caractéristique
essentielle qui sépare le vivant dunod
vivent bien que la définition ne soit
pas évident techniquement ça voudrait
dire qu un mulet n'est pas vivant vu
qu'il est stérile la question s'est
aussi posé pour les virus ou les
cristaux à cette échelle difficile de
savoir ce qui vit ou non à quel moment
passe-t-on la frontière de la chimie
vers la biologie reste que notre proto
cellule auto réplicante et le début de
ce que nous sommes le jour zéro de notre
existence un enchaînement de réaction
ultra complexe qui ne s'est peut être
produit qu'une fois sur terre crue fois
dans l'univers même ce dont on est sûr
c'est que ça n'a pu se reproduire que
dans des régions très localisées du
monde dans l'océan les ingrédients de la
vie sont beaucoup trop diluée voilà
pourquoi on pense que tout a commencé
près des fumeurs noirs des geysers
volcanique crachons une eau acide à
plusieurs centaines de degrés ultra
enrichi en molécules arracher des
entrailles de la terre une véritable
source de vie de laquelle jaillissent
des écosystèmes luxuriants et des
espèces uniques c'est comme un royaume
extraterrestre mais sur terre pour les
scientifiques est ce que ça serait pas
l'endroit parfait pour essayer de
retrouver des proto cellules y voir la
vie se recrée depuis zéro comme il y à
3,8 milliards d'années vous pourrez
alors enfin percer le mystère de la vie
si pour avoir la réponse qu'on est allé
rencontrer le professeur ouvre meilleur
and rich qui travaille à l'institut de
chimie de nice sous la tutelle de
l'université côte d'azur et du cnrs
c'est ecoscience provence alpes côte
d'azur qui a organisé l'interview que
vous pourrez retrouver en descriptions
avec son équipe il est allé prélevée
près des fumeurs noirs ce qui devait
être des formes primitives de vie mais
quelle ne fut pas sa déception quand il
s'est aperçu que la vie telle qu'on la
connaît avaient tous contaminés oui
cette première cellule qui a donné tous
les êtres vivants a tellement conquis
son milieu que sa descendance empêche
tout autre modèle d'émerger c'est pour
ça qu'il n'y a qu'une branche la base de
notre arbre généalogique toutes traces
fossiles d'une chimie primitive a été
éradiquée du coup c'est mort on n'aura
jamais l'occasion d'observer la
renaissance de la vie pas tout à fait il
reste un endroit que la vie n'a pas
contaminé les confins de l'espace
rechercher l'origine de la vie sur les
comètes congelé dans le vide spatial il
existe des vestiges encore intacte de
notre système solaire tel qu'il était à
l'origine les analyses et nous
permettrait de voyager dans le temps
revenir aux conditions qui ont donné la
vie pour sal agence spatiale européenne
va se lancer dans une aventure plus
qu'ambitieuse aborder une comète en
plein vol c'est la fameuse son rosetta
et son atterrisseur fille là et qui ont
fait la une de tous les journaux en 2014
ce qu'on imagine loin
si qu'il a fallu planifier la mission
dix ans avant son lancement en calculant
une trajectoire de plusieurs milliards
de kilomètres pour à terre c'était un
petit caillou aux confins de l'espace
son petit nom 67/p
churyumov-gerasimenko jory pour les
intimes malheureusement tout ne s'est
pas passé comme prévu sur une si petite
comète la gravité très faible tu aurais
le poids d'une pièce de monnaie un
simple souhaité relate dérivés dans
l'espace c'est pour ça qu'on avait armé
filet de harpon pour qu'elles s'arrime
solidement lors de son abordage sauf
qu'au moment fatidique les harpons pas
fonctionné résultat fila et rebondit sur
la comète et disparaît de tous les
écrans radar l'atterrisseur semblaient
perdus à jamais mais deux heures plus
tard miracle fila et recommence des
maîtres après un giga vol plané et
plusieurs bons elle s'est finalement
posé pour de bon at actes hélas elle se
retrouve à dix kilomètres de l'endroit
prévu les rares images transmises la
montre perdu dans une crevasse sans
soleil les panneaux solaires ne peuvent
donc pas recharger sa batterie qui
tombera à plat trois jours après après
presque un an filât et à rassembler
assez d'énergie pour sortir de son
hibernation pendant 40 secondes elle
transmet à rosetta les précieux
résultats de l'analyse de la composition
chimique de la comète avant de sombrer à
nouveau dans un silence éternel mais ces
quelques secondes vont s'avérer être une
mine d'or on n'y a trouvé ce qu'on
espère y trouver et les briques de la
vie 40% de la comète est composé de
molécules organiques c'est juste énorme
en plus son atmosphère contient de
l'oxygène semblable à celui qui on
aspire et on a retrouvé dans son noyau
de l'eau mais aussi du phosphore qui est
un composant essentiel de l'adn c'est
tellement riche qu'on envisage que ce
soit démis théorie qui a apporté sur
terre les molécules du vivant c'est la
théorie de la panspermie nous serions
des extraterrestres venus contaminer la
terre et ce n'est pas la seule
révolution les scientifiques se sont
aperçus que les données de la mission
rosetta pouvait peut-être nous permettre
de résoudre
des plus grands mystères de la biologie
quel est le sens de la vie alors non la
réponse n'est pas 42 pour les
biologistes le sens de la vie est plutôt
une question d'architecturé
je t'explique tu te rappelles de
l'expérience de miller en laboratoire il
a réussi à former les briques de la vie
des acides aminés en les observant y
avait quelque chose de surprenant leur
symétrie les molécules peuvent avoir un
sens droite ou gauche un peu comme ta
main c'est le même objet il ya juste le
sang ce qui change dans son mélange
miller retrouve au autant de gauche que
de droite 50 50 logique me direz vous
rien ne privilégie la gauche ou la
droite sauf que c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on retrouve dans le vivant l'
architecture des molécules de la vie
utilisent quasi exclusivement le sens
gauche elles sont toutes assemblées dans
le même sens on appelle ce phénomène
l'homochiralité du vivant mais pourquoi
ce côté plutôt que l'autre c'est
justement ça le travail du professeur ou
meilleur and rich comprendre pourquoi il
a donc participé a filé par l'équipement
d'un appareil qui permet de mesurer la
proportion de gauche et de droite parmi
les molécules de la comète surprise les
molécules issues de l'espace noûn beau
être qu'au stade purement chimiques et
il ya déjà une petite proportion de
gauche en plus comme sur terre chercheur
a alors proposé une théorie les
molécules du vivant serait modifiée par
la lumière bleue précisément par le fait
que les photons peuvent se déplacer avec
une trajectoire en tire-bouchon sens
horaire ou anti horaire selon la source
qui les aimait on appelle ça une
polarisation circulaire l'hypothèse donc
été testé avec une installation
française formidable le synchrotron
soleil qui permet de reproduire sur
terre le rayonnement des étoiles et il a
effectivement pu changer la proportion
des symétries ce qui implique quelque
chose d'assez fou on sait qu'il existe
des endroits dans l'univers où les
soleils produisent des photons tournant
à droite après diffusion si la vie
venait à s'y développer alors nous
aurons face à nous des êtres peut être
identique mais infiniment plus différent
de nous que n'importe quel monstre qu'on
voit à la télé une deuxième théorie à
prendre celle ci postulant que l'homo
chiralité émergerait d'une anomalie
quantique la violation de la symétrie cp
dit plus simplement si la vie' de gauche
auront été décidés à la naissance même
de l'univers qu'est ce qui nous manque
pour recréer la vie depuis zéro imaginez
demain qu'un laboratoire annonce qu'à
partir de simples atome on ait réussi à
recréer une cellule primordial quelle
révolution ça serait il se pourrait
qu'elle soit totalement différente de
notre fonctionnement pas les mêmes
acides aminés par là-même symétrie ou un
adn très éloigné du nôtre pourtant
personne n'a jamais réussi à faire ça on
a tous les ingrédients juste pas la
recette comme on l'a dit la
caractéristique primordiale du vivant
c'est la capacité à se reproduire sur
notre planète ça passe uniquement par
l'adn ou la rn une très grosse molécule
qui va permettre de créer plein de
protéines qui vont enclencher plein de
réactions chimiques amenant à sculpter
ce que vous êtes l'adn contient toutes
les instructions si tu as des oreilles
de chiens des nageoires de poissons à
gros nez ou une calvitie précoce à 20
ans pour lire l'adn pour le recopier ça
se fait pas tout seul on a besoin d'une
protéine d'une photocopieuse chimiques
l'adn polymérase et comment se crée
cette photocopieuse grâce aux
instructions de l'adn c'est le problème
de l'oeuf ou la poule on ne sait pas qui
vient en premier parce que l'un ne peut
pas exister sans l'autre du moins on ne
savait pas il y a quinze ans car
aujourd'hui ce mystère semble avoir été
un peu résolu la découverte est faite au
hasard pendant la création d'un
médicaments de thérapie génique
celui ci devait se fixer sur l'adn pour
l'activer ou le bloqué ils ont pour cela
mis au point une sorte d'hybride à mi
chemin entre les protéines et l'adn qui
l'ont baptisé la bn acide peptides
nucléiques étonnamment on n'en trouve
pas dans la nature alors que c'est
plutôt simple et plutôt robustes ils se
sont vite rendu compte que ça serait un
très bon candidat pour un ancêtre de
l'adn le chaînon manquant acides aminés
apn arn adn ah si simple il semble
encore ne manquez des étapes
intermédiaires et tant qu'on n'arrivera
pas à reproduire cette évolution nous
mêmes l'humanité ne pourra jamais se
targuer d'avoir compris ils vivent un
grand merci à l'ensemble des partenaires
et aux professeurs ou meilleur enbridge
pour avoir rendu cette vidéo possible
l'interview passionnante fait par toi
nemat art et en descriptions pensez à
vous abonner à l'est les amis
[Musique]